one more time and sure enough
you know because of those in phones out
his pants are down police in Port Orange
Florida on the scene after a call for a
man exposing himself in a park the
suspect Lavon Glenn is less than
Cooperative when police have to chase
him down
man get out of the car
thanks for joining us here on Law and
crime I'm Anjanette Levy Lavon Glenn is
a 49 year old man who police in Volusia
County Florida know very well he's been
arrested several times and is a
convicted felon on August 5th Port
Orange Police found Glenn after
receiving this complaint
porch next to the car I get out and it
looks it looked like he was he had his
dick in his hand maybe I thought he was
thinking like pictures or something his
phone was off okay like at the steering
wheel so I'm like I don't I don't think
that's what's going on but let me just
I'm getting the kids out at the same
time so I get the kids out and I just I
just cleanse one more time and sure
enough
Museum falls out his pants are down
almost to his knees so then that's when
we loaded up and fall about four minutes
later police Tracked Down Lavon Glenn
who's agreed to give a statement Glenn
claims he was changing his clothes it's
a little difficult to hear Glenn so
listen closely
just out of curiosity what brought you
here to change the clock
that out got my underwear let my clothes
back down put my underwear on
tie my shoes and then y'all walk up
here
like while you were changing you have
your phone in your hands at all yeah
okay police then put on some gloves and
it's clear they're going to ask Glenn to
get out of the car Glenn continues to
insist he was just changing his clothes
I didn't do nothing wrong I'm not going
to tell you again you're going to get
taste nothing wrong bro don't hold don't
touch me man sorry for the superbody
don't put your hands up
I'm gonna record this bro that's fine
you're not gonna touch me Davis
as you saw Glenn refused to get out of
the car several times and then said he
would record this whole interaction
himself he also accused the cops of
planning something in his car drugs
maybe then after getting hit with the
taser he takes off
I know I know I get it clearly this is a
problem the officers Chase Glenn in
their Cruisers
black Mazda
[Music]
all right all units if you're not in the
pursuit 10-3 is police code for stop
transmitting
[Music]
literally I think I have the vehicle
westbound Ridge Boulevard minutes later
officers catch up to Glenn and run after
him officers from nearby South Daytona
police join in the chase one officer
even scales a wall
stop
we're still heading north get down
Taser Taser Taser all right you
just hit me
back behind your back now come on
get down on the ground officer stun
Glenn one more time
loosen up loosen up and you won't get
tasy loosen up
loosen up every time you tense up you're
getting paid
yeah go ahead bro Lavon Glenn is finally
in cuffs on the ground but he's still a
little defiant
hold on drop the keys
man if you're not gonna have your keys
drop your keys bro oh come on man drop
them
drop your keys
thank you you know man all right well
you're putting yourself in terrible oh
roll forward
okay
all right ready I'm gonna stand you up
oh one
two
three all right
you gotta help yourself
once Glenn is on his feet officers see
he has an injury to his head
oh sit down
come on I know you're probably busy come
on again sit down
sit down sit down
sit down bro
you need to sit down sit sit do you want
to stand off
I'm sorry
sit down
Glenn faces a number of charges indecent
exposure assault with a deadly weapon
battery on a law enforcement officer
possession of cocaine possession of
cannabinoid fleeing or attempting to
elude and resisting arrest with violence
Glenn was taken to the Volusia County
Jail his bail was set at 23 500 for Law
and crime I'm Anjanette Levy